e
lifestyle le sentier de grande randonnée
de l'iphone sillonnent les douze relief
de l'ouest de l'allemagne ouvert en 2009
il est devenu l'un des itinéraires
pédestres les plus appréciés d'allemagne
le sentier de l'iphone nous emmène d'aix
la chapelle à trèves 15 étapes jalonnent
le parcours pour cette première partie
nous irons jusqu'à gerolsteiner
c'est dans le quartier de korn élimine
store au porte d'aix la chapelle que
commence notre périple un lieu chargé
d'histoire qui rien autour de l'abbaye
bénédictine dont la fondation remonte
neuvième siècle
notre premier compagnon de route c'est
le chef étoilé maurice de boer il nous
accompagnera jusqu'à roden un bout de
chemin qui promet d'être savoureux il
paraît qu'il connaît le meilleur endroit
pour cueillir 17 points de départ du
sentier et le pont sur l'inde petite
rivière qui serpente à travers corne
élimine store très vite nous atteignons
la lande de ce trophée est un vaste
paysage de l'undd humides et de
marécages le climat pluvieux de life
elle est la composition des sols assure
la persistance d'une végétation basse et
buissons 2
vendenheim vic d'un arbre et corinne
rick n'empêcherait cents can en
pachtoune peur de vendre avant pas de
cet art aux retraites est un grande
encore l'expert cap autres
maurice de bourg nous entraîne dans les
sous-bois les champignons ne sont plus
très loin
qu'au point
pas question de laisser ses sept bien
charnues au sanglier maurice de boer a
déjà sa petite idée sur la manière de
les accommoder
son restaurant est situé en plein coeur
d'aix la chapelle ex la romaine ex-la
carolingienne charlemagne en fit son
lieu de résidence et la capitale de
lempire construisant un palais dont la
magnifique chapelle allait devenir
cathédrale lieu de couronnement des
empereurs la cathédrale d'aix la
chapelle est aujourd'hui inscrite au
patrimoine mondial de l'unesco
petit tour au marché sur la place de
l'hôtel de ville où maurice de boer fait
le plein de victuailles
son restaurant est à deux pas de là il a
été aménagé dans les caves voûtées de
l'hôtel de ville c'est l'une des
meilleures adresses
au menu aujourd'hui du turbo accompagné
des cèpes fraîchement cueillies
originaire des pays bas maurice de boer
a choisi aix la chapelle après avoir
exercé son art en france il propose une
carte de mais authentique d'une très
grande finesse sa cuisine fleure bon le
terroir elle est généreuse sans oublier
d'être créative
les filets sont d'abord brièvement
grille et juste assez pour leur donner
une belle couleur
kraft
la liste
des votants
ont été menées à swat a fait jusqu'à
maurice de boer choisi ses produits avec
le plus grand soin pour lui et
l'important est de préserver le goût de
chaque ingrédient
dont la salle du restaurant l'ambiance
est chaleureuse de la grande cuisine en
toute simplicité
des saveurs plein les papilles nous
quittons aix-la-chapelle et poursuivons
notre chemin le long du sentier de
l'iphone
lalande de schtroumpf halte n'était
qu'un avant goût de ce qui nous attend à
présent passer le barrage de travail les
gars bartal et la ville de rügen nous
arrivons dans les hautes fagnes une
région de landes et de tourbières unique
en europe
le parc naturel hautes fagnes ifl
s'étend sur plus de 2500 kilomètres
carrés de part et d'autre de la
frontière germano belge
petite halte à monschau au mont joie
comme on l'appelle encore parfois la
ville aux mille colombages
nous battons le pavé à travers les
jolies ruelles médiévales où le temps
semble s'être arrêté
et au milieu coule une rivière la ruhr
la maison rouge bâti au xviiie siècle
par un fabriquant de draps fin évoque
l'âge d'or de l'industrie textile à
monschau
au café week end nous rencontrons le
chef klaus zimmermann à monza où il
possède le restaurant ouvert tous clar
aux
cars timerman a également créé toute une
gamme de produits fins confiture soupes
sauces et autres plats de légumes et de
viande le café week end les a adoptés et
les propose à ses clients mais c'est
derrière les fourneaux que klaus
zimmermann est le plus heureux
il concocte des plats qui font la part
belle aux produits locaux de quoi
réjouir les habitants de la région mais
pas seulement
klaus timone prépare de la selle
d'agneau de l'iphone accompagné de sa
ratatouille et d'un gratin de pommes de
terre
la selle d'agneau est d'abord dorer à la
poêle avec de l'ail et du romarin
puis le chef recouvre les morceaux de
viande d'une généreuse croûte d'herbes à
base de persil d'échalotes et d'ail
frais
au bout de huit minutes au four à 200°
la selle d'agneau est à point avec les
eaux et les parures le chef confectionne
un fond de sauce il ajoute des carottes
du céleri et
maria
riesch
pour terminer la sauce et déglacer au
vin rouge mais
je ne
de munchhouse à une ruhr les plantations
de haies façonnent le paysage brise-vent
protection pour le bétail et véritable
réservoir de biodiversité
on les trouve jusque dans les villages
les maisons se parent depuis le xviiie
siècle d'imposantes clôture de verdure
pour faire face aux vents glacés et aux
rigueurs du climat de l'iphone à savoir
faire transmis de génération en
génération
nous continuons notre voyage le long de
la vallée de la ruhr et arrivons dans le
nord du parc national de l'iphone à des
deux bornes et ses magnifiques forêts de
hêtres
un biotope sous haute protection
il est strictement défendu de quitter
les sentiers balisés arnaud corp l'un
des gardes forestiers du parc national
est là pour veiller au grain
ici la nature doit pouvoir se développer
à son propre rythme les interventions de
l'homme sont très limités
physiquement
pendant
tout
le match
la couronne des arbres presque
impénétrable forme une voûte verdoyante
c'est la particularité de ses hôtes
forêts de hêtres où la lumière parvient
à peine à percer aux étages inférieurs
la végétation a du mal à se faire une
place au soleil
outre sa richesse forestière la vallée
de la ruhr est aussi un important
réservoir d'eau rien qu'au siècle
dernier trois barrages ont été
construits le barrage de la ruhr le lac
supérieur et le barrage de l'ourthe
sur le chemin qui nous mène au plateau
de dry bornes nous retrouvons arnaud
notre garde forestier il veut nous
montrer un lieu très particulier
de l'ancien village de volaille fun ça
l'église à subsister
l'armée britannique a relogé les 120
familles de la localité dans les
villages alentour le destin de volaille
fun est intimement lié à celui de la
forteresse de vogelsang qui n'était ni
plus ni moins qu'un centre
d'endoctrinement pour la nouvelle élite
nationale socialiste
après la guerre les forces armées
britanniques puis belges prennent
possession du site de nouveaux bâtiments
sont construits vogelsang devient un
camp d'entraînement de l'otan
en 2005 le site est rendu à l'allemagne
et depuis 2006 l'établissement est
ouvert au public
vogelsong est aujourd'hui classé
monument historique
on y organise conférences et expositions
un lieu de mémoire indispensable une des
dernières expositions mettent en lumière
l'utilisation qu'on faisait le régime
d'hitler de la randonnée les nazis
considéraient le sport non comme une
seule source de bien-être mais comme une
arme futur dans les conflits à venir
nous arrivons dans le coeur spirituel de
l'iphone l'abbaye de steinfield fondée
au 10ème siècle depuis 1923 elle est
dirigée par des moines de l'ordre des
salvadoriens
dans la basilique le maître autel se
dresse sur trois gradins une véritable
merveille de l'art baroque
oh
le grand orgue historique de balthazar
que nick aux 35 registre est célèbre
dans le monde entier le frère andré hatz
var leur en est le titulaire organiste
de talent il part régulièrement en
tournée dans toute l'europe
dans la cour du monastère nous
retrouvons le père pancrate sauce le
père bernard tu olrik schrader qui tient
la boutique du monastère et l'apiculteur
claus khalden bar autour d'une bonne
table des fromages et du jambon de la
région déconfiture du pain confectionné
au monastère l'abbaye brasse également
sa propre bière et possède même des
ruches dont classe kaltenbach vient
prendre soin leurs sujets de discussion
n'en est pas moins sérieux depuis
quelques années on assiste à une
véritable hécatombe parmi les abeilles
partout dans le monde les rushes du
monastère ne sont pas épargnés
les causes sont multiples mais le plus
grand responsable et le parasite acarien
varroa originaire d'asie du sud est
introduit en allemagne en 1977 pour
enrayer sa propagation claus khaldoun
par utilise de l'acide formique les
chercheurs ont récemment découvert un
nouveau moyen biologique de lutte contre
ce parasite l'acide oxalique contenu
naturellement dans les épinards la
betterave rouge le thé et le cacao par
exemple cette substance n'est pas
toxique ni pour les abeilles ni pour
l'homme qui la consomment naturellement
dans son alimentation
la disparition des abeilles est un
phénomène très préoccupant leur butinage
est indispensable pour la biodiversité
le père bernard et claus khalden bars
ont décidé de nous accompagner pour un
bout de chemin
près denters i'm au détour d'une
clairière le vestige d'une fontaine de
l'époque romaine le grün c'est la
porte d'entrée de l'aqueduc de l'iphone
qui acheminer l'eau sur près de 100
kilomètres jusqu'à l'antique cité de
cologna cloud yahara agrippine soum
cologne
nous reprenons notre route le long du
sentier de l'iphone prochaine
destination
blankfein dans la vallée de l'aar
au dessus de la ville trônent
l'imposante résidence de comptes de
blankfein
c'est au coeur de cette petite ville
médiévale sous une maison à colombages
que jaillit la source dollar le début
d'un voyage de 90 km jusqu'au rhin
le musée de l'iphone et sa maison des
corporations nous fait découvrir
l'histoire la culture locale et les
particularités géologiques de la région
et on peut même y prendre des cours de
cuisine
monica martens transmet les vieilles
recettes de l'iphone à la jeune
génération
aujourd'hui les enfants vont apprendre à
faire des clins d'oeil des sortes de
quenelles à base de farine 9 et de l'est
un plat ancestral
monica martens en profite pour raconter
aux enfants des anecdotes du temps passé
les journées des paysans étaient longues
et rudes rythmée par l'angélus une
prière de dévotion en l'honneur de
l'incarnation que l'on récite matin midi
et soir l'alimentation était peu varié
il s'agissait surtout qu'elles tiennent
au corps il se nourrissait
principalement de bouillie d'avoine de
seigle ou de pain des légumes et de la
viande amélioré de temps en temps
l'ordinaire
et quels sont les talents culinaires de
nos petits marmitons méthyle la main à
la pâte à la maison
les claudel sont formés entre deux
cuillères à soupe puis poché dans l'eau
bouillante ils sont servis avec du
beurre légèrement noircis et du lard
pour les becs sucrés des pruneaux siro
accompagne tout aussi délicieusement ce
plat
à l'autre extrémité de la ville au
restaurant chose blick nous retrouvons
et en garde et mathias
les deux randonneurs ont suivi le
sentier de l'iphone jusqu'à blanken
rhymes
prochaine étape mir barre ils ont cinq
heures de marche de vente e
c'est parti
cette partie du chemin est aussi appelée
la route du pain au moyen-âge les
paysans qui vivaient dans les villages
alentour devait verser une taxe aux
seigneurs de la région du blé de l'orge
et du pain
c'est cette route qu'ils empruntaient
pour allait s'acquitter de cet impôt à
blanc kenwright
et en garde et mathias s'accordent une
petite pause bien méritée
de quoi reprendre des forces avant
l'ascension du mont du calvaire
le mont du calvaire est une zone
naturelle protégée est l'une des plus
vastes genévrières d'allemagne une
splendide vue panoramique s'offrent à
nous par beau temps la vue s'étend
jusqu'aux os art le plus haut sommet de
l'iphone on peut même apercevoir le
nürburgring
arrivée amir bar entre chien et loup
l'église du christ rédempteur de style
néo roman et sa tour octogonale date de
les mosaïques et qui orne la voûte de la
croisée du transept et le coeur sont le
chef-d'oeuvre du mosaïste allemand à
august oetker
soudain l'atmosphère se fait plus
lourdes les paysages traversés reste
somptueux mais quelque chose a changé et
pour cause la région autour dit le times
est un véritable haut lieu du polar à
tel point que des guides proposent même
des randonnées du crime en y regardant
de plus près on comprend pourquoi
même la riante cascades dry mule la plus
belle de l'iphone prend des allures
lugubre la nuit tombée
le château médiéval de kerpen se prête à
merveille à une énigme criminelle
kerpen un petit village paisible de 450
âmes sans histoires apparemment
qu'est ce qui se trame dans ce petit
café aux abords pittoresque
rien de bien suspect pour l'instant la
propriétaire du café était agressif et
la galeriste marlies beckmann sont en
train d'installer une nouvelle
exposition ce soir les murs du café
accueille des lithographies de andreas
noces man ce qu'a fait c'est un peu le
rêve de thé agrafes
une manière de combiner l'art avec l'art
de vivre
les jolies tarte de théa ont conquis le
coeur de plus d'un randonneur elle
confectionne aujourd'hui une de ses
meilleures tarte aux pommes
à peine un peu partout
or cet art et a besoin d'un kilo de
pommes braeburn
elle prépare ensuite l'appareil auquel
elle mélange 100 grammes d'amandes
effilées
la tarte cuit au four à 175 degrés
pendant une heure environ
ce soir le café affiche complet pour tes
à c'est une vraie réussite
et
le lendemain direction et les stein
à l'hôtel augustine or kloster un
établissement 4 étoiles établi dans un
ancien monastère augustin nous
retrouvons un compatriote le jeune chef
pascal valais il propose des plats
typiquement français à la sauce locale
tels son coco fitz accompagné de pommes
dauphines le fitz c'est un délicieux vin
de pomme de l'iphone il fait d'abord
revenir les morceaux de poulet dans 50 g
de beurre
ils sont flamber au cognac puis mouiller
au vin de pomme
pour lier la sauce pascal valait mélange
un jaune d'oeuf et de la crème fraîche
puis il ajoute des champignons sautés
les pommes dauphines sont un mélange de
purée de pommes de terre et de patachou
que l'on fait frire jusqu'à ce qu'elles
soient bien dorés
le monastère augustin a connu une
histoire mouvementée au 19e siècle ses
portes ferment et une partie du bâtiment
est reconvertie en tannerie l'hôtel hi a
pris ses quartiers en 2007
en allemagne les fans de romans
policiers connaissent bien ils s i'm
cette ville de 3000 habitants a fait du
crime sa spécialité environ 150 auteurs
de polars se sont installés dans les
environs il paraîtrait que l'atmosphère
particulière de la ville les aiderait à
trouver l'inspiration
l'un des plus célèbres d'entre eux ralph
crosby a même fondé à hipsheim est la
maison du crime juste à côté de l'hôtel
kloster augustine heures
ne
retourne pas
folichonne ron
nahman fraudes estime qu
il est également le cofondateur de
l'hôtel du crime tout un programme ici
l'idée c'est de faire fonctionner
l'imagination des clients chacune des
dix chambres a été aménagé avec un décor
unique elle porte le nom d'un des héros
du genre avec un portrait au dessus du
lit sherlock holmes maigret d'eric
dans la salle de bains miss marple
l'ombre d'un assassin apparaît sur le
rideau
la chambre d'eric et meublée dans un
style années 70 avec papiers peints et
machines à écrire d'époque
mais il est temps de reprendre notre
route le long du sentier de l'iphone
prochaine étape guy rothstein